thank you for coming back
um and thank you for asking lots of
questions and for first hour I hope you
still have some left for the second hour
uh because those really helped
so I want to talk about unconditional
lower bounds for mcsp now
and I mean mostly circuit lower bounds
um so just to remind you
that minimum circuit size problem is
this problem of deciding if a given
truth table of a Boolean function has a
circuit size complexity at most on
parameter s
and we really would like to understand
how difficult it is to solve mcsp maybe
it's possible to do the empowerment of
time maybe in polynomial time on average
um so we don't have any unconditional
results for the general problem
I think the best we can say for the
general mcsp problem is this conditional
hardness result that says that if you
have average case complexity if there
exists one-way functions then definitely
mcsp cannot be done in polynomial time
and this is a result
due to rasborough and rudich essentially
um and you know the proof of this
essentially because mcsp is a killer of
generators and from one-way functions
you can get generators and you can kill
them with mtsp so if mcsp lives then no
one with functions can so that's
basically the argument
so it's an average case assumption that
implies the hardest of mcsp
in the realm of conditional hardness
results are go-to would be to show it
can be hard to solve something so that
would be saying like if p is different
from NP then there's no polynomial time
algorithm CSP and this is a big open
question to get the hardness of mcsd but
we that close or as Rahul explained in
his uh introduction so maybe one day
but those results are would be
conditional so what about unconditional
lower bounds and I will talk about
unconditional circuit lower bounds for
mcsp
e so this is a non-uniform model of
computation and of course I'm not going
to show you
um General circuit lower bounds I wish
but we don't have those for any problem
basically let alone frame csps key but
if you allow me to talk about a smaller
circuit classes like ac0 or constant
depth and the like then we can get some
results for mcsp in particular if you
talk about constant depth also known as
ac0 circuits then you have lower bounds
for MCS spear to be of the form to the N
to the one over depth
um I'm ignoring some minor constants in
there so please forgive me for not
burning the notation but it's basically
the state of the art uh with appropriate
constants plugged in
for de Morgan formulas it's a cubic
lower bound here capital N is the size
parameter the input size parameter to
the function that tries to compute mcsp
so it's to the little n normally
and for ac0 mod P circuits that we
talked about earlier uh depth D with
multiplicates or any Prime P the lower
bound is also exponential it's two to
the entropy 1 over 2D profit
foreign
as I said this bounce match the best
known bounds for explicit functions in
mp
and here they prove they can be proved
for mcsp
e
Ed
which is a bit surprising because mcsp
seems like a very complicated function
and normally to prove circular bounds
for some function you need you pick
a function which is not too hard it has
a nice structure that you can exploit to
get the lower bounds going and here you
have very structureless for as far as we
understand very structural problem like
mcsp and it's not clear how to apply the
classical methods of proving circuit
lower bounds to that unstructured
problem
I'm not going to go into details
but usually like lower bounds for the
models that I Define for constant depth
or de Morgan formulas uh you use uh
material techniques like famous ones
like method of random restrictions or
polynomial approximation and I'm not
going to Define exactly what those are
but this is a classic stuff
and unfortunately it's not clear how to
apply those methods to this
structureless problem mcsp in fact
random restrictions work really well for
parity function because parity is like
immune to random restrictions but what
happens when you restrict mcspe who
knows
it's not clear how to analyze that
so we'll be using something different to
prove a lower bounds for mcsp
now in the previous hour I talked about
the power of mcsp as the ultimate killer
of to the random generators
now we're going to use that power
against mcsp
e to show that mcsp cannot be computed
by small class circuit
because we have pseudonym generators
against small classes of circuits okay
so the general framework to prove lower
bounds for mcsp Via prg is to set up the
game where you have a pseudonym
generator
a g which is a good generator for the
class of circuits script C
and then you argue that your mcsp will
be able to break this generator so the
generator does not full mcsp which
implies that mcsp cannot be from that
class C for which the generator is
supposed to work
all right and now you just choose
appropriate see here appropriate G there
and that will give you that mcsd is not
in that class
and then the parameters will just tell
you how good the lower bound to get here
from how good a generator you have for
like how big circuits how big of a
circuit can can it fall in from what
class
it's not the general framework
and as we observed before the break mcsp
is really good at breaking a local
pseudonym generators
so here I'm I'll
May confuse you by saying by giving the
definition of local again but it's more
like a property of local basically as I
said generator being local means that it
can be broken by mcsp that's all I need
here
so the generator is something which
stretches a seed into the output of the
generator of appropriate length here I'm
going to be thinking of the outputs of
the generator as truth tables of Boolean
functions so it's the size of the output
is like capital N which is 2 little n
the same Convention as before
and I say that this generator is local
is if for every sheet to the generator
the output of the generator viewed as a
truth table has sufficiently less than
the maximum circuit complexity
and the maximum circuit complexity is
something like 2 to the N over n
by classical work on circuit complexity
however for uniformly random truth table
for random function the complexity of
random functions or compressional random
function is strictly bigger than to the
N Over N Again by The Classical counting
arguments
so if I set my threshold for the mcsp
algorithm to be this close to maximum
capital N over little n then this mcsp
will break any local generator whose
output has a relatively small circuit
complex
foreign
so this is the framework
this is the takeaway that mcsp breaks
every local G and we just make the size
parameter to be capital N Over N close
to the maximum
so
um just to remind you what does it need
to be prg prg for generator G is it to
the random generator for circuit Class C
if no circuit from the class breaks it
which repeating myself means that if I
have a local prg for some class of
circuits then mcsp is not in that same
class of circuits
and that's what we're trying to use
and some things are very easy and some
things don't require much work you can
just take things off the shelf but some
things need to work
it's on harder to use this approach to
get like strong and strong enough lower
bounds
local prgs are known for a bunch of
models of circuits
the classical one is for ac0 the
original work by Nissan who gave a
pseudo random generator Nissan video
some style based on the parity function
as a heart function
and
therefore immediately you get that mcsp
cannot be nac0 because you have ac0
secure random generator
the size parameter
you have to be very careful like you may
be fine tune some parameters and you can
fine tune them enough that the circuit
lower bound you get will be essentially
the optimal one
let me know
for general for General functions in
class NP
now we also have a generator for uh to
hold de Morgan formulas
of cubic size
um this uh is from the result by
paglazzo Mecca and Zuckerman
and with some improvements by chirakchi
myself Lou and Mary sotis
and before this work like you had a
generator for the Morgan formula so
about quadratic size and these people
managed to push this to larger circuit
complexity and get a generator that
falls bigger things and it's good for us
because once you have a generator full
cubic formulas then you show that mcsv
is not in cubic size to Modern formulas
so good work there implies good lower
Bound for mcsp with respect to Morgan
formulas
so
um what about ac0 multi circuits that we
defined before the break so there's a
constant depth circuits with a modular
Gates multiple gates for Prime p
unfortunately we don't have good prgs
for that class of circuits and that's in
itself a very important problem instead
of randomness
but we do have some prgs
um
and this is coming from the work of
feverman Shelton humans and viola
in the context of hybrid arguments and
limitations of hybrid arguments they
gave this construction over prg with not
very good stretch but still some
non-trivial scratch so what did they
show they've shown that you have a prg
that fools ACC remote key circuits of
weekly exponential size so think of M as
the input size of the circuit that
you're trying to fall so the number of
inputs
so the output of the generator are
passed to a circuit
that takes sorry the the output of the
generator is like some function of the
input size so the generator maps and
plural random bits to M plus M over m to
the Epsilon to the random bits
so normally the generators that we like
have at least polynomial stretch so you
go like from M to M square or M Cube
even better like exponential for pseudo
Randomness exponential is even better
but this generator just only do
this additive stretch here uh the seat
length plus a little bit more
okay and there's a good reason why we
only have this kind of generator and the
reason basically comes down to no good
circuit lower bounds are really known
for
ac0 remote key good enough to construct
a generator from I mean we have weekly
exponential but they're not good enough
to get a good generator like anything
wants
absolutely because majority is not
computable and actually
so this generator from this paper by
February is not local in the sense that
it's not breakable as far as we know
actually I'll may get to talk about this
later it may be broken by mcsp but we
just don't know if it is
okay but as far as we know this
generator is not local in that we don't
know if mcsp breaks it so we don't
we cannot just take this generator and
be done by saying okay mcsp Breakers
therefore mcsp has this weekly
exponential circuit size complexity so
we need to do some work
okay
yes
is it possible like it is a conference
possible like could it be that if you
know if mtsp is not in the class then
ERG is
foreign
so if you have something which is not
strong enough for the problem that
you're trying to solve what do you do
you change the problem you try to solve
okay so that's approach number
workaround number one here that I want
to talk about
and so instead of saying oh
we're going to use mcsp to break a
generator and therefore mcsp will have
high sort of complexity we're going to
say hey mcsp does not seem to be strong
enough we call up its commagoro relative
MK Capital TP and that thing is strong
enough to handle these generators and
we'll be able to break it and therefore
we get that mktp requires ac0 mod P
circuits of size to the end labs
okay
so that's number one I'll talk about
this in a moment but don't worry I'll
talk about how to get mcsd lower bound
as well uh but the result will be a bit
more complicated to stay so please bear
with me
um
instead of saying simple to understand
thing like mcsp breaks a generator we
have to
say the following
sudden restriction of an mcsp
will break
a certain version of that generator
okay so do like we'll find a version of
the generator to break
and we'll also argue that there's some
restriction of an mcsp circuit that can
be used to break it
the size of the Restriction of mcsp
circuit will be of the same size as the
original one
and if you and this version of a
generator will still be a generator so
it will full ac0 mod P with
exponential size
so that would still imply that there's
some restriction of mcsp must be large
circuit complexity and therefore the
original mcsp must also have large
circuit complex what is the restriction
I will talk about that a bit later but
think about this like somebody gives you
a circuit for mcsp and you say
thank you so much but I'm going to
modify it a little bit and the
modification will basically be that for
some positions you say you know what I'm
gonna hardwire zeros in those positions
and will it will like we'll leave them
like that
that will be the Restriction so use the
same circuit but some inputs you're
going to ignore by plugging in zeros in
there such instead before that these
methods don't work here isn't that what
you said that's the usual ways we prove
lower bounds uh the usual way to prove
lower balance would be to say that if if
you have no so usually you say that okay
give me a function that you want to Pro
lower Bound for and if function has nice
structure like then you say oh let's hit
it with a random restriction it will
simplify it will simplify too much and I
can prove it to you and that's
impossible because it can't simplify too
much and that will give you a lower
bounds and usually to argue that
something simplifies enough under random
restriction you need to understand that
that function well enough to really talk
about it like you know you take your
parity functional that's very easy to
understand maybe majority with some work
you can understand but mcspe
what happens when you're heated with a
random restriction what I'm talking is
not quite a random restriction and not a
restriction in the usual sense and I'm
not going to use it to actually say that
the function simplifies
so it will be a restriction of a circuit
but don't think about this as a random
restriction as a method to prove lower
balance
it's not
yes yes
for the normal one yeah
yeah
I could be honest
right and if you left the case that
little video
Arrow averages
yeah
so let me talk about the easier Point uh
item one
and
I will remind you this notion of Haiti
complexity
so personally I think of mcsp as the
complexity like circuit complexity being
an object from the world of circuit
complexity because it talks about like
what is the size of the computational
model that you need to compute a
function
now in the komagoro world
um things are a little bit different
although they similar in that you give
me a description and you also take into
account the time in it that it takes to
recover the object from the description
I'm talking about time-bounded
Commonwealth complexity now as we
usually do in complexity Theory so
Unbound comfortable complexity you can
take arbitrary number of steps but for
the time bounded you need to take into
account the number of steps not just the
description size
for the circuit complexity for mcsp you
just say the circuit size and you don't
really explicitly mention how long it
takes to recover the string the truth
table from the circuit
yes
normally it would take maybe quadratic
time in the size of the circuit because
we work with the chewing Machine model
so you have some polynomial overhead in
the Reconstruction which mcsp does not
reflect
mcst just text about the description
side circuit size doesn't talk about the
time it takes to compute the circuit on
all the inputs
kalmogorov complexity KT is like the
komagora version of circuit complexity
that is fair in that sense it explicitly
talks about the time it needs to recover
a particular bit in the string X
okay so this is like really uh being
from the komogoro world but it's a very
close relative of mcsp
but it's more honest
in that it takes time into account
okay so
um let me say it more formally just in
case so given a string of length n QT
complexity will be
um a sum of two things a program of size
d
uh so I think of the program G
description G
um and the time in unary
number of steps such that some Universal
training machine with random access to
its input tape on an index I can produce
the ith bit of the string X in time T so
like any input position you want you can
recover in at most steps uh given your
random access to the description D and
given the index of the position
explicitly
so this notion of Common Ground
complexity is sufficient for us to argue
that we can break this poor stretch fsuv
prg for ac0 mod P
for every seed that
to the generator G the Commonwealth
complexity commonware of T complexity I
think our whole talk Islanders
complexity so maybe it should be like a
but anyway so komogorov capital T
complexity of the output of the
generator will be its most the size of
this seat plus something small
and I'll explain why
whereas and remember the output of the
generator is going to be
M plus M over m to the Epsilon so it's M
plus almost m
which is very large compared to M plus m
to the Epsilon which is much smaller
so for a random string X of length M
plus M over amplitude Epsilon the KT
complexity will be about M plus M over 1
m to the Epsilon like almost every
string is incompressible and as Rahul
mentioned this is true for any modal
Commodore complexity that you can you
can use it's the pole Falls by counting
arguments
now why
so the second point is easy is by
counting Y is the first point why KT is
a killer of this kind of generator fsuv
generator
well you need to look at what the
generator does
and the generator that fsuv use is
basically a direct product generator for
the function parity let's think about
ac013 circuits here for which you can
use parity to to fool them because ac013
circuits are not smart enough to compute
parity
what you do is you take the input
which you can think of input of Link fan
which you think of as a tuple of K
strings of size M over K and think of K
as being M over m to the Epsilon which
works out for every string in the Tuple
to be of length like m to the Epsilon so
if you do the math the size of the input
here is going to be exactly m
the size of the output or the output
will be the seat itself so you take your
X1 through x k and output them plus you
evaluate your page function on each one
of them and append them at the end
so basically direct product construction
for the parity function but you include
the inputs as well
um
like incidentally Nissan witnessing
generator is normally defined uh where
you just output the values of the
functions on the inputs which are like
partitioned using the clever design
construction and you normally don't
bother including the seat but you could
so one way to save a say this is like
it's like misunderstand generator
without designs
using parity as a heart function
okay like design free Nissan Windows a
strange thing to say but anyway that's
what it is
right there's just no
that's right that's right
yeah yeah it's very simple design it's a
very trivial kind of design yeah where
you don't care about compressing
um
and
this is actually a very interesting
point maybe I'll remember to come back
to this later the difference between
Nissan victorson generator with actual
design and like trivial design or no
design is ambition which is this and
like how they play in terms of context
of learning for example
all right so now that we understand the
structure of this generator
uh let's see what is the KT complexity
of its output
well if you want to compute this string
you definitely need to know the inputs
X1 for XK so that will be part of the
Commodore description the inputs this is
of size M as you remember but the
independency of each XR you can compute
yourself
and it takes more time because parity is
an easy function
and that will give you plus the time to
compute the parity
so KT tells you okay I want to know uh
the bit in this location you say oh
that's very easy it's like a truth table
lookup for appropriate input
um something complicated I want to know
the bits and dislocation okay I need to
figure out which string x i corresponds
to this position and then I need to do
the hard work of computing the parity of
those bits in that strength but that's
time of the parity which is essentially
linear in the size of the parity and the
parity was on M to the Epsilon size
input so that's m to the Epsilon for you
that's it
so that is the proof uh sketch why
KT will kill this generator of fsud
consequence KT
um
mktp function has high ac0 multiple
circuit complexity
that was easy and I should mentioned
that this is basically was done by a
calendar and cauthors and then also by
Rahul and Rich I believe
um so I mean they did a little bit more
huh
both of them well you have a lower Bound
for mkgt against zero multiple okay
using a different different way of
throwing things but you know the lower
Bound for mktp was coming from the work
of Eric and then some improvements from
Rahul and trichy and raholin Street
should basically were using this
framework
all right so
as I promised you I want I promised you
to show that mcsp itself not its
Commodore of relative mktp also requires
a zero multi circuits of high science
um
as Eric can tell you in uh
in a much better way
um there are a few results in complexity
of Commonwealth problems which are much
easier to prove from mktp than they are
for mcsp
e okay and this is one example where for
mktp I've shown you the complete proof
of the lower Bound for mptp assuming you
know the hardness of this uh
of assuming the the security of this prg
from this paper uh by fsuv
but for Ms mcsp you need to work much
much harder because mcsp does not seem
to kill those generators even though I
suspect it does we just don't know how
to prove it well again I'll I'll remind
I'm reminding myself to talk about that
later
so what do we prove
so in a paper with gold of uh Rahul
alango in banglades so myself kolokolova
and Alice sheitel uh we show The
Following
and this is not the way we stated in the
paper but I believe I think it's the
same thing so I hope to convince you I
have a child
check and we'll let will let us know
um so this is how I I'm thinking about
the result from that paper let's fix the
ac0 mod P circuit size complexity of the
function mcsp so let's denote by S of
capital N the circuit complexities like
the size of the best circuit for mcsp
where the circuit is of this type ac0
monetary circuit
of
then for every large enough input length
so there's always a asymptotic as normal
so for large enough input sizes
there exists a prg
which is a good prg against ac0 multi
circuits of large size
and there also exists
and ac0 multi circuit which is of size
at most this Som
okay and this is the Restriction of the
mcsp circuit that I was talking about
uh which breaks the generator G
so this is like more detailed way of
saying that
um there exists a version of the
generator and there exists a smaller
circuit which breaks this generator and
the smaller circuit comes from this
assumed circuit for mcsp of ac0 mod P
type
which side does it look right
Maybe
Maybe
oh yeah yeah exactly yes yes so I didn't
say thank you Ryan
um I didn't say this exclusively but if
you like put these things together then
what's the conclusion well because uh
this circuit C breaks the generator the
complexity of the circuit C must be at
least to the end of the Epsilon because
the generator is secure for those eyes
and the circuit C is of size that most
asked which means that s of n must be at
least within the episode and S of n was
a complexity parameter of complex
designs for the mcsp so the complexity
of ntsp must be at least through the
internet
you don't have a question
oh yeah please
um
[Music]
yeah like this prgg is going to be like
a non-uniform prg
and the circuit C that breaks it is also
going to be like non-informed version of
the non-informed circuit given franchise
so it will be like some kind of
non-iformity added to the things that
you start with uh to get the version of
the krg and a version of the circuit to
break this so it's like you have a
non-informed construction
well that's what makes it interesting
especially other side noting now so it
comes back yeah
it's a different presentations yeah I
wanted to surprise you
I wish I was one of the authors on the
paper which was by the way written at
times during earlier earlier program of
assignments and like so yeah Simons is
very good place for anything
[Music]
so okay let me give you a little bit
more details uh I'm not going to do the
whole thing even though it's it's kind
of interesting but
um just want to bet your appetite maybe
if you haven't read the paper
even though the presentation is
different
but
uh here the fsuv generator that we're
gonna use is a so-called biased coin
generator which I'm going to Define
so the output of the generator and sorry
I'm switching the notation here a little
bit to help myself so the output of the
generator will be of size capital n
think of capital n as like the truth
table of a Boolean function that we
usually do and each of those capital n
Bits will be independent a random
variable set to one with some
probability half minus gamma and to zero
otherwise so it's a bunch of biased coin
flips
with slide bias gamma will be some
function of the size n for us it will be
roughly 1 over square root of n
foreign
so
why is this a generator maybe I should
say why this is a generator
um so if I have like
and bits
and each bit is of this bias
um half minus gamma
then intuitively because it's not a
perfectly
biased thing it's compressible
all right
um like think of gamma to be one half
then it's an extreme case of course but
like it then the whole all bits are the
same then I can definitely compress it
really well
um if gamma is like some constant then
you still can compress it quite a bit
because you know uh there are not so
many sets uh with a few elements from
the universe of the given size
uh unfortunately uh to use this
generator to break ht0 remote p
uh h0 remote p is not that silly
um so it can can distinguish some kind
of bias a little bit
um so you need to have
a bias so that you vary close to one
half
to make it useful okay so gamma should
be kind of very small and when gamma is
very small uh your coin is your bias
coin is almost unbiased coin with just a
little bit
in in the directional being biased and
when you think about compressing this
you'll get a little bit of savings but
not too much
okay so why am I talking about the
compressing of this thing so I'm saying
that this string can be compressed
into something which will be arranged
roughly n times the entropy of one half
minus gamma the entropy of the bias
yeah
and this compression and decompression
are known to be computed efficiently
and this compression can be is known
that does optimal compression like what
I said which is remarkable I find
and it's very simple
and so what is this
uh this is roughly like the binary
entropy function of one half minus gamma
is about 1 minus gamma Square
so this is roughly and
one minus oh sorry one minus gamma
Square
gamma is like
very close to 1 over square root of M
it's going to be slightly less than that
because if it if it was that then this
would be 1 minus 1
I mean this would be
yeah like basically n
right so you would have no savings
whatsoever
if you make it slightly smaller than 1
over square root of n then you get a
little bit of compression going on but
not that much
okay and think of gamma is like one over
n to the Epsilon then you get some kind
of compression here you go from M minus
n Over N to the Epsilon to n
okay I was talking about this generator
before and now I'm talking about
compression what's the connection well
just think about this in Reverse
direction that that will be your
generator
right so because the compression is
optimal and efficiently computable in
both directions
if you give me a uniformly random string
of that size
I can compute the string of slightly
bigger size that will be slightly biased
makes sense
and this is one of the versions of fsup
generators that they mentioned in the
paper but they don't spend too much on
it they just mentioned in passing but
this version of the generator happens to
be exactly what we use in this lower
bound
even though the presentation is not that
but can be made to use that generator
so that's
um the bias coin generator for you and
what is this circuit C
uh the circuit c as I
um mentioned answering tells question is
going to be your mcsp function
um
where the inputs to the mcp's function
are going to be fixed non-iformly in
some places
okay you're gonna fix two things
you're gonna fix the size parameter s
star
here it will be something special that
we have no idea what it is but it can be
found by some kind of averaging argument
and non-uniformly fixed
and in your truth table that mcsp
usually expects to get you will have the
whole truth table except that with some
non-uniformly chosen positions will be
fixed to zeros
you just overwrite so yeah there's some
X2 that comes in as an input but you're
going to ignore what X2 is and just
think of it as 0 always
so that will be the Restriction of your
mcsp yeah
both of these choices are very
non-uniform
we have no idea how to compute them
uniformly so they just appear by some
kind of averaging arguments they exist
ah because I need to know gamma
and I don't quite know gamma
I know it's going to be of this order of
magnitude
but what the constant is I'm not sure
so there will be some particular bias
roughly of that order of magnitude that
will be good for me but which one I'm
not sure but it will exist
welcome that's very good thank you for
asking that's a good question
I'm not sure but that would not be as
cool as this
right Ryan uh I like
all right forget that um
so
um yeah I don't know
because as I said the presentation now
is different from what we originally did
so I haven't thought in the context of
generators what you can do once you have
this idea
so maybe
uh one of the corollaries of this I'm
going to talk about some details of this
Construction in a moment I have time for
that but one of the I find it's
interesting color right so
Rahul talks about the difficulty of
proving and the hardness of mcsp and
empty hardness of mcsp is like showing
that sat can be solved if you know how
to solve mcsp and the reduction can be
any kind of a fiction algorithm that may
use mcsp any way you like it likes so it
could be adaptive you know crazy asking
a specific question a bunch of times on
related inputs whatever
and it's uh there's been a lot of work
and maybe uh Rahul alango is going to
talk about some of that work tomorrow in
the context of disproving that certain
reductions to sat mcsp to sat sorry sat
to mcsp do not work if you restrict your
reductions enough
okay
on the positive side
you can prove some reductions from
non-trivial thanks to mcsp
which follow from this work combined
with an earlier work of aloe vera and
sometime on which in turn is based on
cidk that I talked in previous hour so
combining all of those ideas you can
show that any function in nc1 so
anything which is computable by small
polynomial size de Morgan formulas
can be computed by a constant depth
circuit a c0 circuit which has Oracle
gates for mcsp
and I think it's going to be very
adaptive
so the reduction is very simple ac0 it's
efficient polynomial size but super
adaptive and also non-uniform
because of the reasons that I just
mentioned earlier that don't know the
bias to know the size parameter s pry a
star and which positions to fix the
zeros all of those things will like come
into this non-informity of this ac0
reduction so it's not uniformity zero
reduction highly adaptive probably so
that tells you that like you know you
can use mcsp for solving some
non-trivial problems like anything in
nc1 for example but you have to be
really clever to use mcsp and you have
to be probably using it adaptive if you
want to get some mileage from it which
may also explain why it's so darn
difficult to like come up with such
reduction because in the completeness
world we used to simpler to the simple
reductions
I will make a uniform probabilistic
right now
um
possible possible and I haven't thought
about this after that clearly you can go
through all the money from hearts in
this construction and like they they by
averaging hybrid arguments so yeah you
can have someone trivial but kind of low
probability so I guess probabilistic
will be like maybe with probability like
one more square root of n or something
like that I'm not sure
regimes
so yeah so before I do the summary let
me just give you some
um more details and this is like the
original presentation of this result
um from the paper I mentioned with
Alisha and others
and others where we showed that you can
use mtsp or some restrictions of MCS
restriction of mcsd to break this bias
coin generator and that like what it
means is like you can distinguish
between a sequence of bits which are
Epsilon biased so each bit with
probability almost half versus uniformly
render string which is unbiased strings
and the reason why brake instruction
generator is good for proving residual
mocular balance is that there was an X
result by shorty olympiola who showed
that any distinguisher for this two
cases uniform versus distribution can be
used to get a circuit to complete
majority
and because the majority is a hard
function for ac0 multi circuits your
distinguisher probably cannot have small
ac0 multi-complexity if it can kill
these things
okay now to prove that
um mgsp has montrealances
you just need to show that ntsd
distinguishes these two cases
and we're almost there oh yeah
um the actual thing that we use is that
Improvement of the social dual result
due to the Maya and and others who shows
are more precisely the parameters like
if I have an algorithm that
distinguishes slightly biased from
uniform where the bias is Epsilon then
the distinguisher which does this
distinguishing task gets circuit
complexity of ac0 mods type of and
there's a formula
foreign
so some version of mcsp distinguishes
Epsilon bias from uniform but
that's not quite true
and so let me explain uh to you let me
try to give you an idea like what did
the obvious approach would be and why it
doesn't work because we don't know if it
works and why we had to do this other
crazy things
now
as I mentioned before for cruel random
strings mcsp of the truth table uh will
have like we'll say no with this size
threshold meaning that almost all random
strings have very high surgical
complexity
now what about Epsilon biased truth
table
um so typically if you flip a coin with
probability one being one half minus
Epsilon you expect to have one half
minus Epsilon once fraction once in your
string
um and so yeah so this set with so few
ones relatively speaking will come from
a set of all sets with so many ones
which is n choose half minus Epsilon
times n
which works out to be uh exponential
with this binary entropy function times
n in the exponent I already used that
fact when I talked about compressibility
of this bias sequence
so yeah so this basically says that uh
this string with few ones is
compressible to about this size
that I mentioned before so half minus
Epsilon bias is gives you one minus
Epsilon Square Times n bit size
so
um this string can be specified using
this many bits one minus Epsilon Square
Times n Bits And for mktp that was
enough
for mcsp we need to argue that actually
this string of bias bits can be computed
by a circuit of size 1 minus Epsilon
Square Times the maximum possible size
which is like 2 then over n
M over a little f
and like you know that the now the like
normal description is of this size why
wouldn't the circuit description be like
what you expect it to be like normally
random strings have a bit complexity the
length of the string but the circuit is
like that thing divided by the log of
the length of the Strand okay that's
like usual bounds due to lupanov and
others
so lupano in fact showed that you know
if you have unbiased random string then
its complexity will be at most to the N
Over N or capital N over little n in my
notation here and for biased ones yeah
it's almost like this it's almost like
that so here show the typical Epsilon
biased truth table will have circuit
size 1 minus Epsilon Square Times 2N
Over N so far so good
and I wish he stopped there but then we
have to add some error terms
and the error term is like this n over
little n Square
why is it bad well let's open the
brackets here
so this is like n over m
minus Epsilon Square n over little n
these are my savings from the bias thing
and then plus the error term
and this error term is gonna
eat up all my savings because my Epsilon
will have to be at least like 1 over
little n
actually it would be like 1 over poly
little n
so like all my savings evaporated
because of the error term in lupano's
results
and I'm just wondering if he could work
a bit harder and gotten a better result
then we would have got it like very
simple proof of why mcsp has high
circuit complexity relative to ac0 multi
circuits
but we don't know that so it may be
possible so it may be possible that this
can be improved uh would probably
require a lot of work and I'm not sure
if people really tried
I'm not sure if people are really
motivated to work on that
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like yeah
you have like very good approximations
of these certain complex the random
functions both upper and lower bounds
and it's like it's good here and then
second order error terms we're not 100
sure they're typed and this is one of
those second order
[Music]
and so um the actual proof that we have
to do
um we start with the Apollo result for
constant bias Epsilon for which the
savings is really good because when
Epsilon is constant
some like say one over ten this savings
is like constant fraction n over n and
the error term is then negligible nrm
Square so for constant Epsilon result is
great so we use that
and then we can do the hybrid argument
to go say okay for constant buys we have
small circuit for bias close to one half
they're not sure but let's have some
kind of hybrid argument and argue that
there will be good plays where
um you have some nice gap between like
size of the circuit for this bias versus
limited for the slightly bigger bias
yeah I don't want to go into more detail
than that
um and then you also use some kind of uh
churn-off like concentration results for
circuit size of random functions uh to
finish the argument and argue that there
will be a good threshold to choose that
comes from the hybrid argument such that
there's a good enough gap between small
bias and slightly bigger buyers
and then you do that we're scaling to
get from this to bias versus unbiased
which is random versus slightly biased
and when those are scaling some things
will have to be fixed to zeros you can
be equal to the mcsp function and where
they get fixed you don't know because it
depends on the biases that come from a
hybrid argument and this is the email
uniform part of the construction
but if you do all those things standing
at the result that I mentioned before
that you can break
um a bias Point prg using some
restriction of ncsp circuit that we have
using some new informed choices
so we finish
like summarizing what I talked about
so the takeaway message from my tutorial
here was to say that mcsp breaks local
generators and it's really good for
learning if you have access to HSB
heuristics average cases the algorithms
and it's also good for proving lower
bounds against mcsp with respect to the
glory with classes where you have krgs
and again trichy we're going to talk
about more applications of the
generators
effects
to ask some questions this quick
announcement about the top tomorrow so
sweet she's on well so you won't be able
to speak tomorrow morning but um Eric
and uh Igor have volunteered to speak so
we have not speaking instead
um and no more questions
foreign
[Music]
there's one example I'm trying to
remember
um
we could do a depth to threshold circuit
lower Bound for uh mktp that's still
open
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]